do these new claims over lockdown signal
an end to your political career he'd
been on lucrative speaking engagements
in America
Mr Johnson what are these what's
happening what are the WhatsApp messages
tell us about your behavior during
lockdown at Dulles Airport Virginia talk
of covered lockdown breaches was harder
is your political career over Mr Johnson
sir you're being paid a lot of money on
a speaking engagement in the United
States so I'm going to ask you to please
stand back Mr Johnson will you be
further embarrassed by your WhatsApp
messages during lockdown Boris Johnson
hadn't addressed fresh claims that he
broke covered restrictions heading for a
flight home for the first time he did
you have form in terms of breaking the
law on Covert have you broken it again
no and I I've been here to talk about
Ukraine that's what I've been doing and
why wouldn't you talk about Corvette
you've been accused of Breaking the Law
at Checkers and a Downing Street did you
no but uh you'll look
um it's there if it's proof that you did
are you finished as a politician
the answer is that
um
as I said before there was absolutely no
uh
rule breaking and you know
what proof do you have of that well look
you know those who want to make
allegations should make allegations and
so far nobody has and you're my honest
view I think this whole thing is
completely nonsensical and look I've got
to check in for a flight now the
contents of ministerial Diaries have
been reported to police as evidence of
lockdown breaches if the former prime
minister had been reluctant to talk
about it at first suddenly he wasn't if
you wanted to interview him not happily
talk to you this whole thing is a load
of nonsense from beginning to end and
we've made that clear in the statements
that I've issued
um I think that it's ridiculous that
elements in my diary should be
cherry-picked and handed over to
the police to the Privileges committee
uh without even anybody having the the
basic common sense
to ask me what these entries referred to
what do they refer to there is
absolutely nothing in those entries that
constitutes uh rule breaking during
covid restrictions okay mingling with
friends at Checkers that is absolutely
not what those diary entries show that
is not what those diary entries show and
the whole thing is totally nonsensical
who is trying to stitch you up Mr
Johnson who well who do you think is
trying to set you up
Boris Johnson's office had spoken of a
political stitch up amidst divisions in
the conservative party let's let's go
let's go who is trying to set you up Sir
is it Richie sunach look I think it's
it's where are you come on where are you
yeah I've asked you it's okay he's from
Sky News he's from Sky News he's been
he's entitled to to ask me questions and
I'm going to tell you I just think it's
totally nonsense School you talk about a
stitch up you
for reasons for reasons that
um
somebody somewhere thinks it's sensible
to do this I don't take care of us let's
talk of a skip fire in the Tory party
would you encourage that and do you see
that as a potential comeback for you the
questions fly back to the UK with him
the baggage he can't lose James Matthews
Sky News in Washington